all right hello everyone
since we're coming to this session hope
you're having a good conference
before we begin we'll be sharing a lot
of links but don't worry you'll you'll
find them on the YouTube page whenever
the recording goes up
okay let's start then my name is Ricardo
and together with a current in I will be
talking about the future of 3d graphics
on the web but before we do that let's
have a quick look the past and the
present WebGL landed in browsers in
February 2011 that was in chrome 9 and
Firefox 4 were the first ones those were
so those roses were the first ones who
implemented back then the Google with
the Google query lab we created a
interactive music video that aimed to
showcase the new powers the technology
was bringing to the world it was a
pretty big project in between creators
directors concept artists animators
around 100 people work on the on the
project for half a year and 10 of us
were JavaScript graphics developers we
knew the workflow and tools were very
different compared to traditional web
development so we also made the project
open source so others could use it as
reference some years later Internet
Explorer an H and Safari implemented
WebGL 2 which means that today the same
experience works in all major browsers
in desktops and tablets and phones too
what I find most remarkable is the fact
that we don't have to modify the code
for that to happen
anyone anyone with experience doing
graphics programming like knows that
this is this is rarely the case
usually we had to recompile the project
every every couple years when operating
systems updates or like new devices
appear so the quick recap just double
checking WebGL is a JavaScript API that
binding to OpenGL it allows web
developers to utilize the users graphic
users graphics card in order to create a
efficient and performant graphics on the
web it is a low-level API which means
that it is very powerful but it's also
very variable for example our graphics
cards main primitive is a it's a
triangle everything is done with
triangles here's the code that we're
going to need to write an order in order
to display just choose one triangle
first we need to create a canvas element
then we Chaves cube we get the context
for that canvas and then since things
get pretty complicated like pretty fast
like after defining positions for each
vertex we have to add them to a buffer
send it to GPU then link to link the
vertex and fragment shaders compile a
program that will you will be used in
from the graphics card to how to filter
those pixels so that's why a bunch of us
back then like started creating
libraries and frameworks to that
abstract all that complexities so so
developers and ourselves will say
productive in focus those libraries take
care of placing objects in 3d space
material configuration is loading 2d and
3d assets interaction sounds like
anything for doing any and you sort of
like game on application there's only
designing those libraries takes time but
over the years people have anything like
free amazing projects with them so let's
have a look at what people are doing
today so people are still doing
interactive music videos that's good in
fact like in this example tracked by
little warship not only works on desktop
mobile but it also works on VR devices
letting you look around while chopping
through like low internals another clear
use of the technology is gaming plum is
a beautiful game developed by a super
surprisingly small team and was released
last year last year's Christmas
experiments another one is a
experiences in this case I out the goat
is an interactive animated storybook
designed to teach children about bowling
and the guys that the faucet assembly
used my to model on Rican animates those
characters and then exported to gltf via
blender for rendering the usages and
they brought like 13 15 thousand lines
of typescript to make the whole thing
work and yet another very common use is
a product configurators the guys are
like a little workshop again show how
good this can look in this demo click
but those those cases the not and
they're like what people are doing like
data visualizations enhancing newspaper
articles virtual tours documentaries
movie promotions and more like you can
check you can check the 3js webster than
the babylon Jet Set to see more of those
examples alright we don't want to we
don't want to end up like in a world
where the only HTML elements in your
page is just a combat second script tag
instead we must find like a way of
combining WebGL and HTML so the good
news is the lately we have been like
seeing more and more projects and
examples of web designers utilizing bits
of WebGL to enhance their HTML pages
here's a site that welcomes the user
with a beautiful immersive image we're
able to interact with the 3d scene by
moving the mouse around the image
but after showing the page then we reach
like traditional a static layout with
all the information about the product as
we as traditional web sites usually look
like the personal portfolio of Bertrand
Candice shows a set of developments
affecting the dynamic background it's a
little bit dark with JavaScript we can
figure out
the position of those deep elements and
then we can use that information to
affect the physical simulation that
happens on this 3d scene on the
background but like for underpowered
devices we can just replace that WebGL
scene with the static image and the
websites so functional another
interesting trend we have been seeing is
the web sites that use distortion
effects the worst for Japanese director
of terajima has a very impressive use of
them however the content is actually
plane and selectable HTML so it is
surprising because as you know like we
cannot do these kind of effects with CSS
so if we look look at it again what I
believe that they were doing is like the
edges copying the they had the Dom
elements that they're copying the pixels
all those elements into the background
WebGL canvas then they hide the Dom
element that they apply the distortion
this is the finishing transition and
they put the next Dom on top so it still
it's something that you can
enable/disable depending on there if
it's small also works on mobile some of
the things but something that you can
progressively enhance one more example
to set for this side applies the social
effect on top of the HTML basically
making the layout like look like truly
fluid then again like this is something
surprising because with the maybe
possible avoid CSS so I think those are
all great examples of the kind of
results you can get by mixing HTML and
WebGL but it still required to the
developer to diving into JavaScript on
that you know as we know can be a little
bit tedious to connect all the parts if
you're more used to react this new
library by Poul Henschel I can be a
great option for you react 3 fibre mixes
react concepts on top of three years
abstraction so that like here's the code
that for the animation that which is saw
notice how the like rivers will define
effect and content components easily
composed into the canvas it makes it
feel much more reusable and easy much
and easy to maintain
however I think that we can still make
even simpler and to web components I
believer where components will allow us
to finally bring bring all the power of
WebGL right into the HTML layer we can
now encapsulate all those effects in
composable custom elements and haidle
all the code complexity so for example
here's another project that we did for
the WebGL lunch eight years ago it was
kind of a globe platform it was a like a
project that allow JavaScript developers
to visualize different data sets on top
of the globe you will have the library
you have your data and then you are to
like use different like money to use the
different parts of the data to display
but even if we tried to hide the WebGL
code developers still had to write
custom JavaScript for loading the data
and configure the globe and append it to
the DOM and the worst part was like the
burrows will still have to handle the
positioning of the Dom object and the
reciting and I did was use difficult to
like mix it with like normal SML page so
today with web components we can
simplify all that code we use those two
lines the developer only has to include
JavaScript library on the website and a
powerful custom element is now available
to place whenever whenever they need in
the Dom I'm not only that alike but at
that point I duplicating a line with by
duplicate by duplicating the line that
you can have like multiple Globes before
it will know how to you know duplicate
all the code and it will be again how
they're like more code to read and parse
a component that is already ready to use
the previous one is not ready yet this
one model Bureau is really ready
and for this one basically we wanted to
do that the problem is that displaying
3d models on the web still pretty hard
so we really wanted to make it just as
simple as like embedding like an image
in your page like as simple as adding
like an image stack so that's me that's
the main goal for this one again the
developer only has to include a
JavaScript library and then and then
like a powerful this custom element is
ready to display like any 3d 3d models
were using the gltf open standard an
important feature of HTML tags is
accessibility for low vision and blind
users we're trying to inform them on
both the 3d model like what the 3d model
is and also orientation of the model
here you can see that the view angle is
being communicated verbally to the user
so they can be oriented with what's
going on and also it prompts the for how
to control the model with keyboard and
and I see one easy exit back to the rest
of the page the mala paper also supports
air like a mental reality and this you
can see how it's being is also really
being used on the nasa website so used
by adding the a RI attributes it's gonna
be able it's gonna show an icon and it's
gonna be able to launch the a or B word
for both on Android and iOS for iOS you
have to include the u.s. DC file and
lastly while building the component we
realized that depending on the device
you can only have up to 8 WebGL context
at once so if you create a new one the
first one disappears it is actually like
a well-known a limitation of WebGL it
lots of good practice you only have one
context for keeping memory in one place
the best solution that we found for this
was creating a single WebGL context on
off-screen so like is kid'n and then we
use we use that one to render all the
model b where LM
on the page we also like utilize the
interest in observer to make sure that
we are not rendering objects that not
are not in BO and also recites observer
two whenever detecting if the if the
developer is modifying the size we
rear-end early we have to but we all
know how the web is sooner than later
someone we want to display hundreds of
those components and ones and that is
great we want to allow for that but for
that we'll need to make sure that the
underlying API is or as efficient as
possible so for that now quarantine is
going to share with us what's coming up
in the future thank you okay thank you
Ricardo this was an amazing display of
what's possible on the web using GPUs
today so now I'll give a sneak peek of
what's coming up next in the future
where you'll be able to extract even
more computational power from GPUs on
the web so hey everyone I'm Colton Velez
and for the last two years at Google
I've been working on an emerging web
standard called web GPU in collaboration
with all the major browsers at w3c so
web GPU is a new API that's the
successor to WebGL and it will unlock
the potential of GPUs on the web so now
you'll be asking go Anton we already
have WebGL so why are you making a new
API the high level reason for this is
that WebGL is based on an understanding
of GPUs as they we're 12 years ago and
in 12 years GPU hardware has evolved but
also the way we use GPU hardware has
evolved so there is a new generation of
GPU api's native for example Vulcan that
helped do more with GPUs and web GPU is
built to close the gap with what's
possible in native today so it will
improve what's possible on the web for
game developers but not only it also
improved what you can do in
visualization in heavy design
applications for machine learning
practitioners and much more so for the
rest of the session I'll be going
through specific advantages or things
that web GPU improves over WebGL and
show how it will help build
better experiences so first web GPU is
still a low level and verbose API so
that you can tailor the usage of where
GPU to exactly what your application
needs this is the triangle Ricardo just
showed and as a reminder if this was the
code to render this that triangle in
WebGL now this is the minimum web GPU
code to render it the same triangle as
we can see the complexity is similar to
WebGL but you don't need to worry about
it because if you're using a framework
like three or Babylon then you'll get
the benefits transparently for free when
the framework updates to support what
GPU so the first limitation for that
WebGL frameworks run into is the number
of elements or objects they can draw it
frame because each drawing command has a
fixed cost and needs to be done
individually each frame so with WebGL
and optimized the application can do a
maximum a thousand objects per frame and
that's kind of already pushing it
because if you're on if you want to
target a variety of mobile devices and
desktop devices you might need to go
even lower than this so this is a photo
of a living room it's not rendered it's
an actual photo but the idea is that
it's super stylish but it feels empty
and cold nobody lives there and this is
sometimes what it feels looking at WebGL
experiences because they can like
complexity in comparison game developers
in native or on consoles are used to I
don't know maybe 10,000 objects per
frame if they need to and so they can
build richer more complex more lifelike
experiences and this is a huge
difference even with the limitation in
the number of objects WebGL developers
have been able to build incredible
things and so imagine what they could do
if they could render it this many
objects so Babylon genius is another
very popular 3d JavaScript framework and
just last month when they heard we were
starting to implement web GPU they're
like hey can we get can we get some web
GPU now
and we're like no it's not ready like
it's not in Chrome but here's a custom
build and the demo I'm gonna show is
what they came back to us with just two
days ago so can we switch the demo
please all right so this is a complex
scene rendered with WebGL and it tries
to replicate what a more complete game
would do if every object was drawn
independently and a bit differently so
it doesn't look like it but all the
trees and rocks and all that there are
independent objects and could be
different objects so in the corner in
the top left top right corner there's
the performance numbers and we can see
that as we zoom out and we see more
objects the performance starts dropping
heavily and that's because of the
relatively high fixed cost of drawing
each object of sending the command to
draw each object and so the bottleneck
here is not the power of the GPU on this
machine or anything like that it's just
JavaScript iterating through every
object and sending the command now let's
look at an initial version of the same
demo in Webb GPU and keep in mind this
was done in just two weeks
so as the demo as the scene zooms out we
can see that the performance stays
exactly the same even if there's more
objects to draw and what's more we can
see that the CPU time of JavaScript is
basically nothing so we are able to use
more of the GPU power or GPUs power
because we're not bottlenecked on
JavaScript and we also have more time on
the CPU to run our applications logic so
let's go back to the slides what we have
seen is that for this specific and early
demo web CPU is able to submit three
times more drawing commands in WebGL and
leave this room for your applications
logic I made Renu a major new version of
babylons a yes
Babylon's a yes 4.0 was released just
last week and now today the WebGL the
Babylon Jazz developers are so excited
about what GPU that they're going to
implement full support for web GPU for
the initial version of web GPU in the
next version of Babylon
Babylon's is 4.1 but web GPU is not just
about drawing more and more complex
scenes with more objects a common
operation done on GPUs are say
post-processing image filters for
example def depth-of-field simulation we
see this all the time in cinema and
photography for example this photo of
the fish we can see the fish is in focus
while the background is out of focus and
this is really important because it
gives the feeling that the fish is lost
in a giant environment so this type of
effect is important in all kinds of
rendering so we can get a better
cinematic experience but it's also used
in other places like camera applications
and of course this is one type of
post-processing filter but there's many
other cases of post-processing filters
like I don't know color grading image
sharpening a bunch more and all of them
can be accelerated using the GPU so for
example the image on the Left could be
the background behind the fish if before
we apply the depth of field and on the
right we see the resulting color of the
pixel what's interesting is that the
color of the pixel depends only on the
color of the small neighborhood in the
original image in a small neighborhood
of the pixel in the original image so
imagine the grid on the left is a
neighborhood of original pixels we're
gonna number them in 2d and the
resulting color will be essentially a
weighted average of all these pixels
another way to look at it is to see that
on top we have the output image and each
of the the color of each of the output
pixels will depend only on the 5x5
stencil of the input image on the bottom
the killer feature if web GPU in my mind
is what we call GPU compute and one use
case of GPU compute is to speed up local
image filters like we just saw and so
this is gonna be pretty far from Dom
manipulation I would like react or like
amazing web features like course headers
so please bear with me we're gonna go
through it in three steps
first we'll look at how GPUs are
architectures and how an image filter in
WebGL uses that architecture and then
we'll see how web GPU takes better
advantage of the architecture to do the
same image filter but faster so let's
look at how a GPU works and I have one
here so this is a package you can buy in
stores and can you see it oh yes so this
is the package you can buy in stores and
the huge heatsink but if we see inside
there's this small chip here and this is
the actual GPU so if we go back to the
slides this is what we call a die shot
which is a transistor level picture of
the GPU and we see a bunch of repeating
patterns in it so we're gonna call them
execution units this is these execution
units are a bit like Corazon CPUs in
that they can run in parallel and
process different workloads
independently if we zoom in even more in
one of these execution units this is
what we see so we have in the middle a
control unit which is responsible for
choosing the next instruction like for
example add two registers or load
something from main memory and once it
has chosen an instruction it will send
it to all the alias the ALU czar the
arithmetic and logic units and when they
receive an instruction they perform it
so for example if they need to add two
registers they will look at their
respective registers and add them
together what's important to see is that
a single instruction from the control
unit will be executed at the same time
by all the ALUs
just on different data because they all
have their own registers so this is
single instruction multiple data
processing so this is the part of the
execution unit that is accessible from
WebGL and what we see is that it's not
possible for a use to talk to one
another they will have no ways to
communicate but in practice GPUs look
more like this today there is a new
shared memory region in each of the
execution units where I'll use our can
share data with one another so it's a
bit like a memory cache in that it's
much cheaper to access than the Jemaine
GPU memory but you can program it
directly explicitly and have a use
shared memory there so a big benefit of
GPU compute is to give developers access
to that shared memory region
this was the architectures of GPUs and
their execution units so now we're going
to look at how the image filter in WebGL
maps to that architecture for remainder
this was our the algorithm we're going
to look at and in our example since our
execution units has 16 a I'll use we're
going to compute a 4 by 4 block which is
16 pixels of the output in parallel and
each ALU will take care of computing the
value for one output pixel and this is
GPU pseudocode for the filter in WebGL
and essentially it's just a 2 de loop on
X&Y that fetches from the input and
computes the weighted average of the
input pixels what's interesting here is
the coordinates argument to the function
is a bit special because it's gonna be
pre-populated for each of the L use and
it's what will make it that's what will
make that L use each to the execution on
different data because they start
populated with different data so this is
a table for the execution of the program
and likewise we can see the coordinates
are pre-populated so each column is the
registers for one of the ALUs
and we have 16 of them for the 16 al use
so the first thing that happens is that
the control unit says hey initialize
some to 0 so all of them initialize the
sum to 0 and then we get to the first
iteration of the loop in X and each ALU
gets its own value for X likewise each
register Lu gets its own value for y
and now we get to the line that does the
memory load of the value of the input so
each ALU has a different value of x and
y in their registers and so each of them
will be doing a memory load to a
different location of the input let's
look at this register at this ALU it's
gonna do a memory load at position minus
2 minus 1 we're going to get back to
this one so if we go on and do another
iteration of the loop in Y likewise we
have data Y register and we do a memory
load what's interesting here is that the
first ALU will do a memory load in minus
2 minus 1 that's a redundant load
because we already did it at the nest at
the last iteration anyways the loop
keeps on looping and there's more
loading and summing and all that that
happens and in the end we get to the
return and that means the output the sum
will get written to the output pixel and
the computation for a 4 by 4 block is
finished
overall the execution of WebGL on the
you of the algorithm in WebGL for a 4 by
4 block did 400 memory loads the reason
for this is we have 16 pixels and each
of them each of them did 25 so now this
was how the filter executes in WebGL
we're going to look at how web GPU uses
the shared memory to make it more
efficient so we take the same shader the
same program as before so it's the exact
same code and we're gonna optimize it
with shared memory so we introduced a
cache that's going to load that's going
to contain all the pixels of the input
that we need to do the computation this
cache is going to be in shared memory so
that it's cheaper to access than the
actual input it's like a global variable
that's inside the execution unit of
course we need to modify the shader to
use that input tile and because input
tile needs to contain values at the
beginning
we can't just start like this so this is
dysfunction it's gonna be a helper
function that computes the value of the
pixel and we're gonna have a real main
function that first completes the cache
and then calls the computation so like
the previous version of the shader the
coordinates are pre-populated so each of
GL use does a different execution and
then all the L users work together to
populate the cache and there's a bunch
of loops and whatnots there but it's not
really important so as I use this what's
interesting to see is that only 64
pixels of the input are loaded and put
in the cache there is no redundant
memory loads then we go to the main
computation of the value and likewise
this is very similar to what happened
before but on this line the memory load
is now from the shared memory instead of
the main memory and this is cheaper so
overall thanks to the caching of a tile
of the input the web GPU version didn't
do any redundant main memory load so for
a 4 by 4 block it did 64 memory loads
and like we saw before WebGL had to do
400 so this looks very very biased in
favor of a GPU but in practice things
are a bit more mixed because web GPU did
didn't do main memory loads but it did a
bunch of shared memory loads and it's
still not free and also WebGL is a bit
more efficient than this because GPUs
have a memory cache hierarchy and so
some of these memory loads will have hit
the cache that's inside the execution
unit but the point being overall web GPU
will be more efficient because we
explicitly are able to cache input data
so the code we just talked about in the
graphics world it's called an image
filter but if we look at the machine
learning world it's called a convolution
or a convolution operator all the
optimizations we talked about they also
apply to convolutional neural networks
of
CNN's so the basic ideas for CNN's were
introduced in the late 80s but back then
it was just too expensive to train and
run the models to purchase the results
we have today the ml boom of the last
decade became possible because CNN's and
other types of models could run
efficiently on GPUs in part thanks to
the optimization we just saw so we are
confident that machine learning web
frameworks such as tensorflow JS will be
able to take advantage of GPUs to
significantly improve the speed of their
algorithms finally algorithms can be
really difficult to write on GPUs in
WebGL and sometimes sometimes there's
just not possible to write at all the
problem is that in what year where the
output of computation goes is really
really constrained on the other hand GPU
compute that web GPU has is much more
flexible because each ALU can read and
write memory in at any place in the GPU
memory this unlocks a whole new class of
GPU algorithms from physics and particle
base food simulation like we see here
two parallel sorting on the GPU mesh
skinning and much much many many more
algorithms that can be offloaded from
JavaScript to the GPU so to summarize
the key benefits of web GPU are that you
can have it increased in complexity for
just better and more engaging
experiences and this is what we have
seen with babylons is it provides
performance improvements for scientific
computing like machine learning and it
unlocks a whole new class of algorithms
that you can upload from JSC PU time to
run on a GPU in parallel so now you're
like hey I want to try this API you're
in luck the web GPU group at the web GPU
is a group effort and everyone is
onboard the Chrome Firefox edge Safari
they're all all starting to implement
the API today we're making an initial
version of a GPU available on Chrome
Canary on Mac OS and other operating
system will follow shortly to try it you
just need to download Chrome Canary on
Mac OS
and enable the experimental slag and
safe web GPU and again this is an unsafe
lag so please don't browse the internet
with it on for your daily browsing more
information about about web GPU is about
available on web GP dot io so there's
the status of implementations there's a
link to some samples and demos running
to forum where you can discuss what GPUs
and we're gonna add more stuff to this
with articles to get started and and all
that what we'd love is for you to try
the API and give us feedback on what the
pain points are what you'd like the
thing to do for you but also what's
going great and what you like about it
so thank you everyone for coming to this
session Ricardo and I will be at the web
sandbox for the next hour or so if you
want to discuss more
[Music]